the funny thing is the competitors that
you select it's an arbitrary list right
because no none of the big competitors
are the companies that take you down
like
myspace didn't even know facebook
existed you know uh
you know all the publishing houses
didn't they ignored amazon they turned
down investing in amazon you know all
the movie companies and all the
television stations thought netflix was
cute
right
they were nbc cbs and abc and fox were
so focused on each other they literally
were ignorant to the threats coming from
outside and it's because old thinking
with old players and again it's only
because they're doing what's familiar
you're taking somebody who's a senior
executive at a company who's come up
through an industry who's been doing the
same thing for 20 or 30 years and now
you're going to say
stop all of that
there's new ways of thinking i need you
to completely unlearn everything
and it's not that that can't be done but
as human beings we say to ourselves well
what i've been doing has
worked perfectly fine for 30 years i
think i know what i'm doing i'm okay
thanks very much netflix is such a great
example
because
the then ceo of blockbuster
remember them
uh
and blockbuster was the 800-pound
gorilla i mean it was the only
significant uh national video rental
chain in the country right
huge company
um
and we knew this new technology called
streaming was available and it wasn't
quite good enough yet which is why
uh netflix was experimenting with a new
pricing model if you remember with
subscription and you could get the dvds
keep them for as long as you want send
it back and then then replace them and
then eventually they knew they knew
eventually that would become streaming
and the ceo back then
saw that this was significant and he
went to the board and said i think we
should experiment with a subscription
model and the board would not allow him
to make that change you want another
reason
because 12 of their revenues came from
late fees
oh wow
and they were too
afraid
to lose 12 percent of their revenues so
instead they lost the whole company
and that's the problem which is
sometimes you have to take a short term
hit to innovate especially when it comes
with experimenting with new models and
the joke was it wasn't an experiment
because another company had already
proved that it had validity worth
working that's the folly the folly was
there was no risk they were just
short-term
uh finite thinkers that were thinking
about the the all they could think about
was losing that 12 percent